Salut, aujourd'hui je vous fais une de mes énigmes préférés !
Et juste avant, je vous donne la réponse de l'énigme d'hier.
Si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier, regardez la vidéo d'hier avant d'écouter la réponse.
Je vous l'ai dit: "lampadaire" ça touche.
"Fauteuil": ça touche pas.
"Canapé": ça touche.
"Caméra": ça touche.
Le touche touche pas, c'est le fait de parler de quand les lèvres se touchent ou pas.
Quand je dis le mot: "Touche".
Mes lèvres, elles ne se touchent pas.
Par contre quand je dis: "Touche pas", "pas".
Là, les lèvres se touchent.
Donc: "Touche pas", touche.
Alors que : "Touche", touche pas.
Vous pouvez vraiment vous marrez entre amis,
à faire ce jeu devant quelqu'un d'autre sans jamais lui donner la solution.
Il doit comprendre.
Et de temps en temps, vous pouvez lui dire: "Ah ba tiens, tu vois "bouteille"..."bouteille", ça touche."
C'est à lui de trouver la logique.
J'espère que vous allez rendre plein de gens fous avec ça, c'est vraiment très drôle à faire
et on passe tout de suite à l'énigme du jour.
Cette énigme n°30, est une énigme un petit peu de logique, de mensonges et de vérité,
comme on a pu faire déjà précédemment.
Avec un homme un homme fictif que nous appelleront...euh nous appelleront Raymond !
Voilà, Raymond est sur une île déserte.
Et sur cette île déserte, il rencontre 2 tribus.
Donc déjà, il se dit : Tiens, elle est pas très déserte mon île déserte.
Il y a la tribu des Mental et la tribus des Vlogs.
Parce que c'est l'île du Mental Vlog !
Il apprend que dans le tribu des Mental on dit toujours la vérité, toujours toujours.
Alors que dans la tribu des Vlogs, on dit toujours l'inverse, on ment toujours toujours.
Mais bon, comme on s'est que c'est la tribu des vlogs, on sait qu'il faut inverser les réponses.
Et en se baladant sur l'île, il rencontre 3 personnes !
Team, Menthe et Alo.
Donc il rencontre ces 3 personnes qui s'appellent Team, Menthe et Alo !
Mais qu'est ce que s'est bien trouvé les prénoms dis donc !
Menthe lui dit: "1 seul de nous 3 est Mental."
Alo lui dit: "Nous sommes tous les 3 de la tribu Vlog."
Donc ma question est : Des 3 hommes, lesquels font partis de la tribu Vlog ?
Donc la tribu qui dit toujours l'inverse de ce quelle pense, qui ment toujours.
Et lesquels font partis de la tribu Mental et donc disent toujours la vérité.
Il y a une logique, il n'y a pas d'embrouille, il y a vraiment une logique qui va vous permettre de trouver la réponse.
Dès que vous l'avez trouvé, ne le mettez pas dans les commentaires, laisser les autres chercher.
Mettez juste: "J'ai trouvé" et surtout mettez un pouce en l'air pour savoir qui avait trouvé la réponse à l'énigme !
Passez un très bon samedi et surtout un très bon samedi soir si vous faites la fête ce soir !
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an.
Rendez-vous donc demain à 11h, je l'ai déjà dit.
Ciao !